all of us exist in some way outside of
the mainstream you know we are all non-n
normies on some domain on some axis
maybe dyslexia or color blindness or
left-handedness you know neurodiversity
you know being on the Spectrum how about
take that as a hidden superpower by
which you can stand outside of whatever
the mainstream narrative is and use it
as a way to interpret it in such that if
you do it with integrity and respect to
um open up your arms to more of humanity
you guys are the Proprietors of the
Darkhorse podcast and this is the second
Weinstein I've had on the podcast
actually the third I've had a Zev in the
background as well uh he's doing some
work with me here at UC San Diego but um
I'm grateful to your brother Eric for
helping to facilitate this and I am
grateful to you guys for agreeing to
match the length of time that he has
spent on my podcast in the next 26 hours
so everybody sit back and
enjoy uh so it's a pleasure that's with
PE breaks is that is that right no bio
breaks will be provided damn so you guys
have written a wonderful really
fascinating new book called a hunter
gatherer Guide to the 21st century
subtitle Evolution and the challenges of
Modern Life guys the first thing I do
with all my guests is what you're never
supposed to do which is to judge a book
by its cover but rather than read your
thesis which I did do and I will get to
that in a minute this is the first book
that many of my my audience members will
be familiar with or have a chance to
encounter so what else can they judge it
based on so guys where did the title
come from um and where did uh and where
did the cover art image come from is
that the two of you guys Gathering
hunting on the cover making making yeah
there we go thank you there it is uh is
that us Brett I I wish I could claim it
was us I wish as a fallback I could
claim it was actually our most recent
common ancestor but given the
populations that you and I come from I
don't think that's plausible either that
person was an
agriculturalist yeah no that's that's
presumably true but um yeah actually the
design before we talk about the name of
the book the design of the cover was
actually one that Brett and I had in our
head and we actually mocked it up and
sent it to the excellent artists at our
wonderful publisher and this is this is
what resulted so um you know we're very
pleased with that but the but the title
a hunter gatherers Guide to the 21st
century is of course a reference as
Brett just said to uh the ancestors that
we had in the Paleolithic on the African
Savannah which is what so many people
have in their heads when they think of
human ancestry human prehistory you know
what it was that we used to be doing and
you know people even imagine that it's
that it's the thing to which we must
refer if we are to live our our most
adapted lives and really one of the
premises of the book is we don't have
just a singular singular environment of
evolutionary adaptedness we have many
environments of evolutionary adaptedness
and so sure we are adapted to the
African savannas of the Paleolithic and
the coasts the African Coast but also o
more recently to being agriculturalists
as Brett said um almost all modern
humans are the descendants of
agriculturalists for 10 to 12,000 Years
and we're also pre-industrial ists and
you go farther back the opposite
direction in time from that cover and
we're all primates we're all mammals
we're all fish we're all animals and you
know we we bear the mark of all of those
moments of our evolutionary history
there's also a little wink in there uh
to The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
because of course there there's a little
analogy here right our the argument in
the book the most Central one is that we
in the 21st century despite this
environment effectively having been of
our own making are somewhat out of our
depth like an Earthling traveling the
cosmos so uh that that's where it comes
from and I think maybe we conclude that
actually a towel is not going to be
sufficient useful yeah yeah unlike un
like in Douglas Adams Sher guide and
there's plenty of fish and uh the the
the answer to all of life's questions is
also revealed in here with many many
tips from you guys and I want to get
into that especially parenting tips but
before we do uh yesterday Heather in
your honor I took my clan uh to the
World Famous San Diego Zoo and I wanted
to do some field workor to kind of
Channel my inner Heather highing before
the uh interview that I knew we'd
conduct today and so I captured an image
at Great danger to myself and my
membership I captured an image of of
this little guy I'm wondering if you can
recognize who that is Heather
gosh I I I think that must be an
amphibian I can barely see is it
possible it's a it's a noot or is it a
frog is a frog of some sort yeah hard
hard to see any chance you one more time
kind of look like a tomato frog is that
well it's
red it might boy yeah it could be a
tomato fry discovered from an Islander
from an
island it's
probably it's does look like a man at
all is it a Mella it's not a Mella very
good I was hoping to trip you up Heather
but I couldn't trip you up it is a tree
frog it is from Madagascar but its name
is as Brett said the sambava tomato
frog yeah very good amazing you guys you
haven't lost a bit since graduate school
whereas I have lost everything uh except
for my hair that's all I get to keep
actually we've seen that frog in person
yeah I'm sure it's poisonous so I'm sure
Heather you've done battles with with
even worse uh with worse entities than
this little plump fellow um he doesn't
look dangerous but looks can be
deceiving right um so I want to ask you
first Heather what is so fascinating
about frogs that could make you know we
do our dissertations here about you know
Grand unified theories and and about uh
new cosmological models predating the
existence of the big bang when SpaceTime
didn't even exist what about a frog
could possibly envelop a person in an
entire PhD and perhaps their career as
it did with you at least early on that's
that's actually a terrific question I
mean I was I was interested in the
beginning in uh the evolution of
sociality evolution of territoriality of
Parental care of sexual selection of sex
roles and sexual behaviors and you know
one thing I used to say when I was a
professor to my students is you can be
question driven or organism driven as an
organismal biologist and many people are
just driven to like I really want to
work on wolves I really want to work on
whales and frankly if you're driven by
the organism you are probably going to
be asking less deep questions overall so
I was driven by the the questions that I
was interested in and I started working
on primates and as it happened the very
first field season that I was working
which was in Central America I had a
hypothesis about what particular fruits
the local monkeys would be choosing and
I they were just Mia the monkeys were
missing an action could not find them
and what I did find instead was sort of
a natural experiment playing out in
front of me with regard to in in Central
America was the dart poison frogs which
out to have no relationship to the
poison frogs of Madagascar but that sent
me to asking well there's an entire
island nation larger than the state of
California which has been closed to all
vaza all foreigners for at that point
many decades just opened up no one knows
anything about what's going on there
with regard to the behavior of any of
the organisms except the Lemurs anything
I find will be new and I know what I'm
interested in again you know social
systems and and sexual behavior and
territoriality
let's go so yeah the frogs are
fascinating but it was really more about
uh studying questions that I had a
pre-existing interested and that's how
you know that's also how we end up
landing at studying humans as as
reflected in this book so they're sort
of a model in an interesting way the way
that you know you biologists use by the
way I I am not known for my biological
uh you know competency or my
evolutionary I I always say in high
school when I had to dissect the frog
the frog always lived I mean I I was not
good at this at this at this job um well
then you may not realize the most
interesting thing about frogs is that
they are self assembling ah tell me more
tell me more how does a frog self what
does self assembly mean self assembly
means that it requires that you do this
within a species but uh one egg and one
sperm when they come together causes a
frog it just all happens no one has to
put it together there's no instructions
it just emerges from that beginning ah
interesting so you know I've been called
a self-made man who worships his creator
so I'll be sure to use that uh as an
exampler um in the book Brett you in the
chapters so I I have the book in
physical and digital and in audio form
and I recommend everybody buy at least
three copies so it can continue to climb
from number four on the New York Times
bestseller list to number one uh as it
deserves and I want to ask you guys at
least until my next book comes out but
uh I don't think it'll appear up there
uh but I want to ask you Brett in the
chap one of the chapters that you read
sort of towards the end you talk about
experiment ments and and in the book you
might make the case that as as actually
the New York Times posits you know in
their kind of mini blurb you know the
evolutionary biologists uh posit that
the modern world is out of sync with our
ancient brains and bodies first of all
do you agree with that little snippet or
I thought it was a little bit more
Nuance than that Brett what do you make
of that yeah let's put it this way
there's certainly an important uh more
than a grain of Truth in that but the
the real lesson the much harder one what
we argue in the book is that because the
modern world is so different from all of
the environments in which we adapted the
map of what we are and how it fits the
world is arbitrary there are some ways
in which it just happens to remain a
good fit and many ways in which it's a
terrible fit and one has to look uh on a
trait by trait basis to even figure out
where we have to alter something in
order to again be at home in our own
world and in the book there is sort of a
ominous looming you know kind of thought
that is we're you know we're doing all
these experiments because as we get
farther and farther away not necessarily
as you guys argue you don't argue in
favor as I was surprised you don't argue
in favor of the say the paleo diet and
the keto diet so I went down to Dunkin
Donuts and I want to thank you guys for
that uh because you know uh I had only
lost five pounds as I said I dropped
five pounds from my chin to my to my
backside but I want to ask you guys if
you have this notion that kind of
reoccurs that we're doing all these
experiments we're experimenting with our
kids he you talk about screens and and
and all you know the availability of
pornography which we're not going to get
into and and all sorts of you know
gender selection we're not going to get
into that either uh but that's not not
my interest but the notion of an
experiment I think is it shouldn't get a
bad name and that's not because I'm an
experimental astrophysicist I think it's
experiment is pure play it's pure a
curiosity and I think curiosity is
probably one of the most undervalued
traits what do you guys say about this
categorization we're doing an experiment
on our kids what's wrong with
experiments well the problem is that we
have two meanings for the word
experiment one of them means hey this is
novel let's see how it goes and the
other is we'll make a change and we'll
see what the consequence is and so when
you say there's nothing wrong with an
experiment there's a question about
what's at stake right you know if you're
going to put an egg in the microwave the
worst thing that's going to happen is
you're going to have some cleanup to do
right so you can afford to run that
experiment and not be uh overly diligent
about figuring out how you're going to
collect the evidence but when we're
running experiments on ourselves and
even worse when we're running
experiments on our children and future
Generations it is incumbent on us to
figure out what it is that we are
introducing to their environment and
what its consequence is likely to have
been so that if it's not a good thing we
can reverse it and we are not doing that
we are changing so many things at once
and paying very little attention to the
causality of the pathologies that in
effect we just keep treating symptoms
and adding more pathologies to them yeah
I I agree with this I would say you know
the book is certainly not a call to
regression or traditionalism or you know
a past really
imagined uh history that we could return
to even if we thought we should and we
we don't we don't we think neither that
we can nor that we should want to um but
it is a caution against simply moving
forward with all possible paths because
rather in favor of I would say a
scientific approach to experiment in
which we say here's the hypothesis what
are all the possible uh predictions that
follow from the hypothesis and how would
we know what the outcome would be as
opposed to sort of a a free market
driven in places where there should be
more regulation approach to uh approach
to you know human everything and there
is very little understanding too often
of you know what childhood is what our
brains are what it is that we're
actually losing when we open up some of
the boxes that we're opening up and
hopefully not finding Pandora written
all over it um exactly hey friends just
a short request to ask you to use your
thumb while my thumb is occupied to
leave a like on this video and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode again at the zoo yesterday there
as I was researching your beloved uh
amphibians or whatever they are um
things that I could dissect and still
live uh this um this thing came to my
mind that my kids uh after seeing these
exotic creatures from galopus Turtle
tortoises uh to you know the most
magnificent giraffes were leaving and
they spent more time obsessing you know
just paroxysms of Joy over the American
Red Squirrel and there was a squirrel in
the parking lot and I'm like great you
know did can maybe go check out that
pigeon over there guys you know he could
have saved me 500 bucks um wonder what
is it about hyper novelty that competes
with kind of you know mundanity in a
sense that why are we wired for why why
would we have reason to think that we're
more wired for novelty rather than for
familiarity I guess that's my my
question Heather yeah well you know it's
you're absolutely right and one of the
things that we find when we travel um
before we get into deep nature that may
be the goal of where we're going is that
in the cities where we are we're sitting
around looking at say the grackles uh
which are of no interest to the local
people but they don't happen to be where
we are and we actually uh you know we
would be more like your children perhaps
and be watching the squirrels uh because
because they are fascinating and
certainly there are some there are some
domesticates or uh I guess just
Associates of humans that have become so
common even um even for us that we don't
spend a lot of time noticing them but uh
it is it is absolutely true that
familiarity need not breed contempt but
it does create a kind of a a background
level of I know that's there I'm not
going to pay any attention to it anymore
and so I mean this is this is akin to
our unending search for growth which is
not unique to humans but of course
because we have become so so dominant on
the planet it is the thing that is
likely to be our end and so you know we
argue in the book for for a way to do an
end run around growth that actually uses
resources and seeking novelty that
actually requires totally new things so
um you know those organisms that have
sought novelty uh and have been
risk-takers have been often the ones
that didn't make it back uh but when
they did make it when they were
successful they were the ones who
founded New lineages so you know of
course there is a longstanding you know
as old as 3.5 billion years on earth a
long-standing interest in Exploration of
which novelty is a
manifestation and Brett novelty as you
talk about a little bit is you know conc
commenton in some level with risk or
with exploration to learn something new
requires Discovery to increase you know
entropy is natural to decrease it is is
more uh energetically uh challenging um
as I was coming into to work today it's
the first days of school here at UC San
Diego I saw uh some some young people
skateboarding as is the most popular mod
mode of transportation outside of
surfboarding
and they weren't wearing helmets and
they were uh instagramming I could tell
and uh but they were wearing masks and I
found it very interesting this this you
know incredible and we're not going to
talk about coid obviously but but I want
to ask you guys uh but maybe Brett first
but what what is this notion of of human
beings are we good at assessing risks
and are we good at
predictive um you know Behavior to
predict those types of Novel things as
you guys so cogently argue for that'll
be beneficial to us and not actually
detrimental in any way to us
and we tend to underemphasize these true
risks of not wearing a helmet on a
skateboard while you're
Instagraming well I would argue that in
an ancestral environment in which the
population had been in the same place
doing the same thing for Generations we
would be absolutely excellent at
assessing risk and in fact assessing
probably isn't even the right word you
would in it risk you know the way one
does while driving you can be having a
conversation that's occupying your
conscious mind but some part of you is
paying attention to everything out there
and at the point that something you know
a truck swerves in front of you suddenly
it captures your attention but you know
exactly in that circumstance because you
do have a long history of driving and
you've seen a certain amount you know
what to think but for a modern person
what should you think about the safety
of
ingesting uh a fruit from the
supermarket that has been grown with uh
molecules that we have no evolutionary
history with that you don't even know
about that's not labeled on the Apple
anywhere what it was grown with so how
do you assess the risk of that and how
do you know whether your model's any
good right if if there's some danger for
example that you might come down with
Parkinson's if you spend years eating
fruits and vegetables that have been
grown with these novel compounds at what
point do you reassess your model and say
hey I probably got that one wrong and
how do you know that it was the fruits
and vegetables rather than that new car
smell from the vehicle you purchased or
you know the way your carpet's off gas
or right we've got again this goes back
to the question of experiments we're
running so many experiments at once and
not being systematic about collecting
the evidence that we really have a very
poor sense and I'll say one more thing
which
is we notice very frequently that our
civilization has an absolute obsession
with protecting you from provable risks
in the short term and it is absolutely
indifferent to exposing you to likely
risks in the long term that are outside
of the bounds of provability and this
has a lot to do likely with the fact
that the way the system gets good at
this is through litigiousness and so
anything that can't be proven is
effectively treated as if it doesn't
exist even if we can infer that it most
certainly must which which creates
perverse incentives for risk to not be
provable m M very good uh the uh figure
of GK Chesterton figures large in this
book and many of my listeners will be
familiar with this quote that uh does
not appear in hunter gatherers guide
when a man stops believing in God he
doesn't then believe in nothing he
believes in anything Heather how do you
react to that you guys are not
proponents of any particular religion
although I I was delighted to learn you
do celebrate Hanukkah in your own
special way at the very end um but uh
what does that mean to you what do is
Chesterton you know can we selectively
apply chestertonian uh quips when when
uh when it suits our fancy as in the
case of the fence or what do you make of
this the uh believe in nothing if uh
doesn't believe in nothing he believes
in everything is God some sort of
connective tissue and what purpose does
evolutionary speaking does God serve
well that's a that's a fascinating quote
and it's not one I've heard so let me
take first uh the the question about
whether or not we can selectively choose
the thinking of of a person and not
Embrace their entire uh mil and I would
say of course we can right uh so uh let
me just take a step aside from your
question for a moment and say
specifically the contribution of
Chesterton that we introduce in the book
and or you know introduce within the
confines of the book not to the world
but right um is is chesterton's fence
the idea that if you see a fence and you
don't know what its purpose is you
should not be allowed nor couraged to
get rid of it until and unless you can
can demonstrate that you know what's
what its function was supposed to be uh
and presumably also demonstrate that it
no longer has that function or it is
infect causing more harm than good and
so we then apply that more broadly and
say we can we see chesterton's fences
all over the modern world in the form of
chesterton's breast milk chesterton's
play and chesterton's religions so to
get to get to your point here you know
what what role does religion have in the
modern world well the idea that it is uh
that we're done with it that it was uh a
Mal adaptation that it was a dangerous
or a mind
virus cannot hold up to evolutionary
scrutiny right every every society that
we know of has some form of religion in
which the people in it the the majority
of people in it until the very modern
times in which we are living in you know
multivariant societies multi
multi-religious societies has has belief
and it helps organize uh uh morality
frankly uh and the idea that it is
somehow additional to uh cheesecake for
uh humans is uh just it doesn't fit and
I wonder I suspect that Brett has more
to say on this perhaps yeah I think the
problem you know we we do talk about
chesterton's fence specifically in the
in the context of religion but you know
we have these two concepts that we
discussed there's the precautionary
principle and there's chesterton's fence
and they're really mirror images of each
other other one is about the hazard of
adding novel things to a system and the
other is about taking away things that
have been long-standing
and again this goes back to the
arbitrariness of the place we find
ourselves in history because we have
these Traditions the Traditions are
clearly not up to the challenge of
navigating modern hazards you know the
Bible has precious little to say about
social media and the hazards of
algorithms to our Collective sense
making well I would actually push back
on that right because there are trat I
mean you may know from your upbringing
there's a sense of there's a a notion of
what's called lashan Hara the evil
speech in Judaism at least which is the
notion that um gossip is not something
that's false in other words it's you're
forbidden to lie in general so it's you
wouldn't be forbidden again to tell
something so it's something that's true
gossip is true uh and yet it spreads
like wildfire more than ever and the
analogy that's used typically uh in in
the talud is is is one of uh you know a
man you know be smch the reputation of
his Rabbi and says oh he's been married
and divorced or whatever and that's not
you know socially a great thing for this
particular man and the parishioner then
feels guilty and says how can I Rectify
what I did to you Rabbi and the Rabbi
says simple just go get a feather pillow
and the guy goes okay I'll go get a
feather pillow that's it that seems
simple Rob says no no no cut it open gu
all right cut I'll cut open the pillow I
don't and he goes Shake It Out Shake It
Out and the guy say all right I'll do it
am I forgiven he goes no now go out and
collect all the feathers the notion
being that you know the ability to
produce BS and and and actually Truth uh
far outstrips the ability to do it but
the notion of guarding your tongue the
actual quote in the in the Torah in the
Old Testament the Bible is you know you
should guard your tongue it's predicting
your life to choose life means to guard
your tongue against this true but
defamatory in some sense speech so I I
wouldn't say that the Bible doesn't
speak about it but with respect I would
say that it it has many aphorisms uh and
the question is yeah which ones do you
know to take seriously I know that
that's a harder problem right well no I
think you've picked a great example
because there's certainly a relevance if
gossip is bad then the internet is an
amplifier of that Badness it doesn't
make it better it makes it worse on the
other hand there's a whole lot that
isn't covered there right like what
happens when it isn't people deciding to
say or not say but it's algorithms
decide designed to increase somebody's
bottom line that result in people being
fed things that flatter their
preconceptions and having things hidden
that would cause them to challenge those
preconceptions that isn't mentioned and
I'm not saying you couldn't find some
analog for that in there but the basic
point is come on these texts were built
by Evolution they were built by
Evolution with reference to environments
we don't live in some of what they've
got contained in them is still as
relevant as ever some of it is upside
down and backwards and much is simply
not covered so when you're left with
that kind of an arbitrary map the
question is what do you do and you know
the the atheists and the way that that's
been formulated in in recent times don't
have it right chesterton's quote is
relevant there the religious people who
say hey this stuff is still you know the
word of God and we have to take it uh as
handed to us don't have solutions to
some of the problems we face and so you
know Heather and I are not happy about
the message that we actually have to
confront the process of building New
Traditions that are up to the challenge
of uh regulating the way we interact
with each other and the world because we
are bound to get many things wrong in at
least our first and second attempts um
but what choice do we have we live in a
world for which no one knows the best
rules yeah and it's kind of that that
you know emerging from the cave that I
find so you know instructive
illustrative um but again just to not
belabor the the religious point I mean a
lot of what you talk about in this book
both of you guys are are really the case
in some way not for religious or you
know uh political conservatism you know
for sure but but really for take
extracting the good thing you talk a lot
about Community about the campfire
that's a strong metaphor we're going to
get into that and how in modern times
the internet is becoming a perverse
campfire and some sense but but religion
is community small groups hundreds of
people go to synagogues not millions of
people or temples or churches or
Buddhist shrines you guys mentioned
Buddhism in the book as well um as a
positive example of a credential
religion that has adaptivity built
within it so I guess the the Gathering
and hunting within the religious
structure it would seem that religious
life offers a lot of what you know the
laune that your book is designed to fill
in some sense um in terms of you know
parenting I mean you basically talk
about you know discipline but also love
and and and um you know kind of having
those two hands everything being this
double-edged sword that the Bible speaks
about so I mean why not just shortcut it
why why should you know why should we
listen to you two brilliant you know
scientists we can say this tradition has
been tested for thousands of years you
know AB tested group tested you know why
not just pick a religion happen maybe
choose the religion you were born into
and and stick with it even if you don't
believe it I mean I had Freeman Dyson on
my first guest he's a he called himself
basically what I do you know in some
sense a practicing uh agnostic so why
not just you pick a system it's been
group tested long time and uh instead of
trying to you know kind of make the
rules up as we go go along now what do
you guys think about that I would say
that's a great start and gets you a long
way in a lot of regards but uh it
doesn't necessarily tell you what to eat
and uh whether not to let the LED lights
Flash in your bedroom at night and uh
what to adopt of uh what modern
authorities are telling you about how
you should form your relationships you
know when it's possible that if what
you're trying to do is simply where your
book the religion that you've picked has
an opinion if you go with that you are
more likely to be right than if you had
nothing to guide you at all um but
having a book that is as you say AB
tested you know time tested all of this
with an evolutionary understanding of
what we are and what we've been because
what we are is far more tested than any
book that humans have created you know
because we are not just hunter gatherers
we are also monkeys and primates and
mammals and fish right we are all of
these things and you make up case
Heather I think in the section that you
read um that I loved you know you really
make the case for abstinence I don't
mean like puritanical it's just you
should you should practice fasting in a
certain sense and and many religions do
that uh took pretty good effect
refraining from you know pornography
from things that didn't exist in the
pre-evolution past and I I I just want
to thank you for that because I I do
think there's a benefit to it you know
we just had yum kapor in our religion
and you know my kids fasted from you
know from dinner to breakfast or
whatever and but but they recognize that
it's good and that they wanted to do it
uh but they couldn't do it and I think
like all the more so in Judaism we don't
use screens we don't you know
communicate on the Sabbath and things
like that you also advocate for that
kind of the digital detox you talk about
taking trips for weeks with your
children that I don't know if they were
what age they were at but you know you
turn on the phone and all of a sudden
you get riddled with with email and that
suggests to me you guys do take sabbaths
too thought maybe talk about the
importance of that in terms of
recharging the human uh you know what
the what the human needs either one of
you is wait I I want to go back and and
push back on something you said earlier
because it really gets to the heart of
the matter here right why not just
accept some time tested religion and go
with that right but how did it get that
way and the implication is partially uh
carried in your argument for AB testing
the fact is sectarian disagreements are
the fodder by which selection refines
belief systems to make the time tested
versions that we have but the other part
of that which we are for in our book is
that there is a mechanism for radical
upgrade as well and you're right there
you know people will struggle if you're
a conservative and you look into our
book you will see conservatism if you're
a radical and you look into our book you
will find radicalism what the hell is
that do we not know what we're doing no
the argument is actually that there is a
tension between these things and that
when you are faced with circumstances
for which you don't have the answers
they're not contained in whatever book
it is that you inherited from your
ancestor ERS you have to have a
mechanism for figuring out what the next
book is going to say and it doesn't
involve sitting down to write the next
book right it involves people around a
campfire proposing things to each other
and figuring out what the foothill might
look like and then that Foothill is
ascended by disagreements and you know
you might have two populations do you
follow the shoe do you follow the gourd
you know that sort of thing and uh those
groups that have or those lineages that
have a belief system that more
surgically suggests behaviors that are
adaptive will out compete groups that
have Messier versions of these things so
in any case I I think the point is do
you want to subscribe to the book you've
been handed or do you want to subscribe
to the process that created those books
in the first place and what our book
argues is that that process is an
evolutionary process and we know where
we are in that right we are at a point
where where uh a radical transition is
necessary if we're to survive so if if I
may um speak to the question of Sabbath
which uh strikes me as having at least
two very important aspects one is that
it allows you to remember who you are
and who you are with and to be focused
on the people both yourself your inner
world and the people you are with and uh
of of course we need more of that in
modern in Modern Life and uh This Is
Fundamental to what humans are but the
other aspect of Sabbath um which you
refer to and yam kapor of course um also
does this is is uh that it it reveals
the benefit of privation and um too much
of modern life is about seems to be
about maximizing comfort and making sure
that we are never in any way outside of
the bounds which we had imagined we
would be outside of and we argue at
least implicitly throughout the book
although I'm not sure we ever explicitly
say this that actually pushing up
against the bounds of what both you
think is possible for your own body and
brain and emotions and what is actually
possible is actually itself Health
enhancing and restoring and so for
instance uh you know obviously we should
be moving our bodies some every day you
know we should all be walking some
amount of time every day but that's not
sufficient we also should be absolutely
pushing our bodies to the Limit
sometimes so that our bodies know what
it is to be pushed and what kinds of
places we might need to push it and that
is going to be the thing that makes us
stronger and more antifragile and so you
know living a life within sort of narrow
conf or even fairly broad confines where
we never where we never even approach
those boundaries makes us fragile yeah
and I see that even in the in the you
know kind of ability to identify with
someone who's truly hungry I mean I've
never been truly hungry you guys have
probably because you've been on such
Amazing Adventures some of which are
documented in the wonderful book that
we're discussing a hunter gatherers
Guide to the 21st century authors uh Dr
Heather hying and Dr Brett Weinstein and
this uh this this book talks about you
know kind of the the the just culturally
it's it's just it's a true wakeup call
but I came to think of it as a
interesting dichotomy and what Brett was
just saying a couple minutes ago between
like what do you choose and how do you
know how to choose and I saw fundamental
dichotomy between producers and
consumers so you guys are producers and
consumers but your producers your
YouTube channel which is extremely
popular Dark Horse podcast you can find
everywhere podcasts are sold um and uh
and but you're also consumers you consum
voracious
um uh you know scholarly and and
otherwise now I started to think about
uh the very first gripping opening story
about rain in the mountains and I
started to think well it's great that
that your guys and we maybe you guys can
recap the story very briefly uh how you
almost weren't here to tell this story
and you almost didn't have the children
that you wonderfully are blessed to have
um maybe tell that story and then I want
to um make the point that there's a
certain amount of credit that goes to
you guys for being consumers and knowing
I should trust this guy this this Guru
uh because he is a producer of this
knowledge but there's an obligation of
the consumer as well and I wonder if
that's not harder to act to acquire um
then but maybe Heather can you start off
with the story about raining in the
mountains and then Brett can you comment
on the obligations of the consumer if he
or she wants to survive and
thrive yeah uh so it was our first
season as graduate students as as
wouldbe scientists in Costa in Costa
Rica we had spent a summer previously
exploring
uh Central America so we were not new to
these ecosystems or we didn't think we
were but we had both grown up you know
privileged kids in Los Angeles in the
weird world it wasn't called the weird
world then but um we were very much of
the first world as it was called then so
we were at this little tiny uh Field
Station in sataki in northeastern Costa
Rica and we were done with our fieldwork
for the day it was hot the two of us
chose to walk down to the river where we
would swim where we would swim many days
uh to get there you have to to cross a
high bridge a relatively High Bridge and
we were about halfway across when a man
we did not know uh a man we we took to
be a local farmer uh approached us our
Spanish was terrible at this point he
spoke no English and uh he basically got
our attention and kept saying there was
rain in the mountains today and he would
point to the mountains and we were just
getting hotter and hotter standing there
wishing that we could extract ourselves
from this conversation but feeling that
we needed to you know engage with him he
was trying to engage with us but uh at
some point he pointed with increasing
urgency to the water and said look and
in the few seconds that we had been
looking away it had begun to rise and
what he was telling us without you know
with the very few words that we shared
between us in a language that wasn't
ours although we were in his home and
you know in his in his home landscape uh
where the language that was spoken was
his was that rain in the mountains that
all of us are aware of that has to go
somewhere and had he not stopped us what
we what we stood on that bridge as that
water Rose and Rose and Rose and very
soon There Were Trees coming down the
river and the bank on which we would
have been standing had disappeared under
this flash flood this man saved Our
Lives probably at least one of ours and
uh we were young protoscience in
graduate school you know working towards
phds uh doing tropical biology thinking
that we knew a place because we'd been
there for several weeks studying you
know frogs and bats but we didn't and so
you know the point is that it actually
takes much longer to truly know a place
and all of us feel like locals now uh in
whatever landscape we walk into but in
fact it takes a lot more experience than
most of us give credit for and actually
you can uh you can see the very same
thing in the tragic videos that emerged
from bonda a for example during the
Boxing Day tsunami where people many of
them who lived on the coast but whose
ancestors hadn't been there did not know
what to make of a sea that had radically
receded and revealed you know sea floor
that they had never seen before and many
people walked out to look at the fish
flopping around right and uh were killed
because they didn't know how they didn't
understand that that water was going to
have to come back um so anyway yes there
is something to be said about really
knowing a place and that's that's what
saved us in in the instance of the the
incident on the bridge so Brett as a
consumer what kinds of you know
obligation there may be obligations on
producers and they may get benefits uh
they may have increased you know
facundity if they're perceived as being
the repository of wisdom of local
knowledge of life hacks as we call them
now we didn't call them back thousands
of years ago um but what obligations are
there on the consumer uh and what
benefits AC crew to him or her for being
astute in their judgment of perception
of which mountain guides to listen to so
to speak to torture this analogy well
I'm I'm a little unsure of what you mean
by consumer do you mean in the economic
sense somebody no just like you're
hearing the information but there is you
you were astute enough something in you
guys listen to this guide or listen to
this farmer and that saved your life um
but not everyone I would have you know I
would have been you know probably the
former Brian Keening I would have I'm
hot what are you talking about man let
me let me take a dive off this waterfall
to impress my girlfriend um but you
didn't do that so there there's some
there was something in you guys that was
astute enough or perceptive enough and
I'm kind of asking I'm in hopes that it
wasn't based on something unique to your
guys intellect or you know something
that we normal people perhaps can
cultivate to be more perceptive
consumers in that sense of wisdom of of
of past Traditions or or even of you
know of these predn naturally gifted you
know people in our culture I'll take a
slight detour uh just yeah something
that act entally revealed something to
me about this which is uh I'm not a
Believer really in dyslexia because
reading and writing are so new that to
say that you have a defect with respect
to them really doesn't make any sense
right this is some thing modern humans
have chosen to do and some of us are
less Adept at processing the symbols but
if dyslexia was a thing i' have it in
Spades and it has an impact therefore on
the way I read it makes it less fun more
uh it's more exhausting for me I know
than people who read easily but it has a
positive upside which I think non-
dyslexics don't necessarily spot which
is because I know I can't trust my
interpretation of the symbols on the
page I'm constantly looking to see
whether or not what I'm reading makes
sense right because the way I know that
I've misread something is that it
doesn't make sense and so then I know I
have to go back and reread it but lots
of times if you if you get good at this
process you're reading something doesn't
make sense you go back to find what
symbol you've misunderstood and there's
nothing you just know it doesn't make
sense and so I guess my point is I'm not
a big believer I think you should really
minimize the consumer part of you that
even what we do that looks nominally
like being a consumer like reading
shouldn't be a passive activity it
should be one in which your uh conscious
mind is actively engaged in evaluating
what's coming in and the profit comes
when you know if somebody's telling you
something and they're ostensibly an
expert in the topic but they say
something that doesn't match the model
that you have of the universe well
there's an opportunity there either
they're about to learn something or
you're about to learn something and that
you know I think deciding to be a
consumer as little as possible is
probably the best advice that that we
can give can I uh can I add something to
that actually um I think all of us exist
in some way outside of the mainstream
you know we are all non-n normies on
some domain on some axis and you know it
may be dyslexia or color blindness or
left-handedness or uh you know
neurodiversity you know being on the
Spectrum um or many many other other
things and you know it's become very
fashionable now to identify what way in
which you are impressed uh this is not
that this is
how about take that as a hidden
superpower by which you can stand
outside of whatever the main the
mainstream narrative is and use it as a
way to interpret it in such that uh or
rather with tools that maybe all the
so-called normies don't have right and
this this actually allows you to have
insight and I think really if you do it
with integrity and respect to um open up
your arms to more of humanity and to
more of the the wisdom and wealth of
skills that that humans bring and you
know I've said I've said before that uh
the many years that we spent teaching in
college classrooms at a you know yes
public liberal arts college but a
non-elite one one that had yes students
from the tops of their classes but also
students who had been completely
destroyed by school and um students who
were the first in their families to go
to college and you know and Veterans and
you know single mothers you know all
range of people what that experience
taught me in part uh was that almost in
a room full of 25 or 50 students almost
everyone has something to teach every
other person in that room and that's not
to say that I was pretending that I
wasn't the professor and wasn't there to
teach some particular things that I had
written into the curriculum and that I
wanted to get to um but that part of
what we were doing there was uh indeed
to return to the the earlier concept you
know was building Community such that we
had trust for one another such that we
could over time reduce the skepticism we
had for one another and thus engage more
and more deeply ideas that might have on
the first day of class seemed polarizing
or extreme well no now now that we have
some trust and you can recognize that if
I say something that you widely disagree
with you know it's not because I'm a
monster Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm not
wrong maybe you don't have the
information I have maybe I don't have
the information you have but let's take
the time to EXP
yeah and I think that is of course the
purpose of Education the Latin root is
educari it means to pour out of not to
put in to I want to talk if you'll
indulge me I wanted to talk about this
later but I Heather you just brought it
up you guys were uh famously um you know
unemployed from Evergreen State
University or um uh and um I think it's
kind of a tragedy um when I look back on
it and I read your writings and I know a
little bit about each of you just
because we're you know friends with uh
Brett's brother
U but the but the point of you guys as
natural Educators as born Educators as
Educators defining who you are and I
remember I got my pilot's license in the
1990s and on that day I remember my
flight instructor saying now your
identity is forever changed you will
never not have been a pilot you know and
it becomes a part of who you are even
you're Fly I'm flying little tiny sesos
you know that I can't fit in anymore and
uh and now um but I I can do that and I
can go down and rent a little plane but
you guys aren't professors anymore and
and yet it's it's sort of like your
clause or or your or your uh web
spinning ability or your honey making of
like it's what you guys were born to do
clearly it is and I I I won't tolerate
if you guys disagree with me because you
guys are human you know incarnations of
Education machines I want to ask you how
is it dealing with the abil with the
fact that you're not teaching you're
teaching you're teaching at much bigger
scale your Publications are read by way
more people that your H index will be
much higher but you're not at a
university how how does that make you
guys
feel um it's it's an interesting
question let's put it this way it was a
tragedy but I don't think it was a
personal tragedy I think what happened
to us was a preview and we are all
suffering this tragedy and I will say um
Heather and I I don't think have talked
about this explicitly maybe we have but
when the I mean I prefer to think of us
as a catapult out of the academy is what
happened to us when that happened to us
we were asked as we were invited to
speak various places how shall we
introduce you right what are you now if
you're not a professor and we adopted
professors in Exile as our um as our I
don't know what it would be title mon
yeah um but the the point was that was
actually uh yeah it was you know there
was a wink involved but it was also an
accurate representation it was a little
bit like your pilot example the point
was well we did that that's still who we
are didn't change the day we resigned
our positions um and I think it still is
and as you point out we are now not in
the same millu we are still teaching in
a new way we're figuring out how to do
it and uh I don't I don't feel I feel a
loss surrounding something that actually
isn't so easy to do at most uh colleges
or universities we had by virtue of the
way teaching was done at Evergreen we
taught one class full-time students took
one class full-time and that class could
go on for a full year which resulted in
a level of understanding between
teachers and students that is
unparalleled and um I missed that but
were we to suddenly have positions as
professors somewhere else that part
wouldn't be restored right it would be a
dim shadow of that and uh what we have
now is quite different but uh it it has
not eliminated the sense of meaning that
accompanies every day and the sense of
meaning is closely aligned to the one we
had when we were in the classroom I I
agree with that and I would say you know
there are catchphrases in educational
theory that people are probably familiar
with and that sound ridiculous at this
point things like lifelong learner and
Theory to practice right um and yet you
know both of those things be the idea of
being a lifelong learner is actually
foundational and I you know my my father
has been has been dead for eight years
now but he was a computer scientist who
didn't view himself as an educator um
but was a mentor to so many people and I
think in the same way we sort of became
accidental Educators because what we
were were were children who were
becoming adults with a curiosity about
in our case largely you know the natural
world and the human world uh that didn't
stop you know any day that uh you learn
something new and this was something
that my father used to say to me any day
I learn something new was a good day
right and it doesn't take very much from
there to then want to share not just the
thing that you learned but how it is
that you can open yourself up to a a
personality of
learning yeah and of course you guys
make the strong case that tools are more
important than facts you say that in the
book and I wonder you know one one uh
very old tradition in weird countries
and maybe had can you define weird
really quickly please yeah just uh those
those people living in countries that
are Western educated industrialized Rich
Democratic or at least aspire to be
Democratic small D but right um I wonder
One institution that's quite old and I'm
wondering and I'm curious if it is not a
chesterton's fence is the University
system which dates back in its current
incarnation of a guy or gal I guess
lately uh with a piece of rock you know
scraping on another piece of rock you
know behind their body IES um in front
of you know these bewildered and bemused
young people uh that they dates back to
at least 1089 in the city of bolognia
and Northern Italy and I I wonder that's
been there a long time it hasn't changed
uh and yet Brett you just mentioned a
few minutes ago maybe a preview what
happened to you might be a preview could
it happen to me should it happen to me
not not exactly what happened but is
Academia a chesterton's fence should we
should we not respect it it's been
around for so long why Advocate to
change it or what are would you Advocate
to change about
uh yeah this is a tough one because my
sense is uh if the academy didn't exist
it would be necessary to invent it and
it doesn't exist so it is now necessary
to invent it um no it's it's become the
maligant version or you know I you know
I realize who I'm talking to but at some
level the the argument that I make is
it's like your cherished family dog
having caught rabies right so you're
you're vaccinated against that
understand yes we are but but the basic
point is look at the point your family
dog has caught rabies it's time to grow
up and realize that's not exactly your
family dog right and the university
system is like this now I think that's
tragic and I think it's crazy obviously
most of the resources you need to build
a great Academy exist in what we
currently call The Academy but it's not
functioning that way and the worst part
about it is that the population of
people that staff the academy have lost
track of what it is they're supposed to
be doing right they just don't do the
work and you're using that sensul lot
you're talking about the faculty largely
yeah it is the faculty I mean I there's
also a lot to be said about the uh the
bloating of the administration and its
role in this but the point is the
university has begun to see itself or
Beyond begun to be to see itself it sees
itself as a a business or it sees itself
as a dispenser of Truth not a place in
which vigorous challenges are dealt with
in a responsible way so that we can
discover the truth and until it either
returns to its roots or gets replaced by
something that is capable of doing the
job civilization's in serious trouble
because you know this this isn't the
14th century right we have problems that
are serious and require very careful
analysis and you absolutely need at
least a scientific apparatus that is
capable of telling you what you need to
know rather than what you want to hear
and in a context where we have markets
plugged very directly into our research
system that's not what we get right we
get some product that interfaces with
our Collective well-being arbitrarily at
best more often than not it might be
predatory and you know that's just
that's that's a dire situation to find
ourselves in you see things in
commonality just to push gently back
with respect um you see things that are
sclerotic that don't change you know
Healthcare you know destruction of of
lowincome family housing and education
these can't be exported at least in
their you know in the exact Incarnation
that I'm sitting in this University um
are they not antifragile are they not I
mean what is what is the this has been
around for a thousand years almost in in
more or less its current state and
except back then they had a barbaric
tradition I don't know Heather and Brett
if you know this but they had a barbaric
tradition that the students could go on
strike and then the professor wouldn't
get paid and thank God they've abolished
that thank um but uh but is it not
antifragile you guys talk about this uh
resiliency as a as a model Heather are
these universities that that I'm a part
of at least currently so um so
entrenched in and so part of culture as
it is uh that they're effectively
resilient to further pertubations and
change well I think uh sclerotic can
look antifragile and it can persist in
in appearing to be effective for a long
time after it actually is so um I you
know we're already seeing some of the
smaller places fail around the edges
right uh the elite institutions and the
large State institutions especially the
r1s are likely to last for longer and um
you know maybe maybe they can
reform uh the places that were once
exactly where undergraduates at least
were most likely to get a really
inspired and exciting and serendipitous
liberal arts education the you know the
elite private liberal arts colleges are
most likely to fall first uh they just
you know they they are they are less
sclerotic um and more likely to be taken
over so you know the idea that the
entire system is antifragile no you know
just as Brett said do we need do we need
higher ed yes we do but that doesn't
mean that the system we've got now is
what will persist but I also think uh
that Nasim TB formulated this concept so
brilliantly that it covers this right
the academy is
robust it's very hard to displace it
that's not the same thing is antifragile
Right basically it survives by
preventing challenge it does not grow
stronger with Challenge and uh I think
that's one of the strongest indicators
that it has in its current form outlived
its usefulness so maybe sclerotic is
robustness not antifragility yeah an
indicator of robustness interesting um
one of the many neologisms you describe
in the book uh is the Omega principle
and I want to read to you from Amazon um
the Omega principle is a brilliant and
engaging book that works on many levels
as AR rousing environmental Manifesto of
seafood and the Quest for long life is
that what you're talking about Brett no
Omega-3s no that's no what is it my
friend tell me not at all okay so
there's a book called the Omega
principle you should you might get you
might get you might hear from their
publisher now we do yes well we've been
playing with this concept for a long
time I'd be curious how old that book is
but in any case the idea is that there
is a fundamental question when you
consider the evolution of humans of our
species everybody understands since
roughly 1976 when Richard Dawkins first
introduced the concept of cultural
evolution in a rigorous form that we
have culture and that it evolves by
rules that are similar to genetic
Darwinism what the field has never fully
resolved is what is the relationship
between the evolution of things at the
cultural layer and the evolution of
things at the genetic layer and Dawkins
himself argues that the cultural layer
is effectively he calls it a new
primeval soup right effectively it is a
new Evolution of stuff a place where
adaptation is uh happening um in a novel
form we argue that that cannot be right
right most creatures do not have culture
we are adapted to have a tremendous
mendous amount of culture we make the
argument that human beings though not a
blank slate are the blankest slates that
selection has ever produced and that
there's a reason for that and that's
because being the blankest slates we end
up uh doing the bidding of the genes far
better than we would if the genes
hardcoded our Behavior to a much higher
degree and so the Omega principle
specifies the relationship between
epigenetic phenomena including culture
and the genes and the reason that we've
chosen Omega is that as a Greek letter
it evokes Pi Pi specifies the exact
relationship between the diameter and
the circumference of a circle in the
same way that the Omega principle
specifies the exact relationship between
epigenetic phenomena and the genome and
that relationship says part one
epigenetic phenomena are more flexible
and more rapidly adapting but part two
they are obligated to the objectives of
the genes and once you make that once
you realize why that logically has to be
the case it makes evolutionary analysis
of human beings tractable because in
some sense you do not need to know where
the information is housed in order to
know what its objective is and this is
crucially important in the case of
something like let's say human language
where the capacity for language is
clearly largely generated by genetic
programming which creates a brain of a
certain uh that is hospitable to
language but it does not encode any of
the content of the particular language
you will learn right it's housed in both
places well how do you factor that to
figure out what what it's supposed to do
well the answer is it doesn't matter
what the ad mixture is in terms of where
the uh the hereditary information is and
how it is passed it's for the same
purpose either
way and I want to ask you a famous
question posed by Irwin shringer but not
answered in his famous monograph what is
life Heather what is life and then I
want to add um another monograph
suggestion to you Brett uh what is
culture along those same physical lines
perhaps so Heather what is life to you
what is life um life is self organizing
and replicating with hereditary
information
that I think self-correcting
hereditary the the hereditary
information has to be uh have error
correction in there too I I have to
think about that to make sure that has
to be part of life but I think so I
actually like John Lennon's formulation
somewhat better life is what happens
while you're making other plans other
plans that would have been a simpler
answer
yes so just just like you said the frogs
were self-organizing right yes that's
your point early on yeah all you were
doing was saying it's alive it is alive
um so now you want culture culture okay
well so this is the part where I'm going
to tangle myself in knots to avoid a
tiny little exception that I'm aware
exists and is going to force me not to
say something very simple and intuitive
um but culture is information it is
adaptive information pass outside the
genome and the caveat it would be very
easy to say something like between
members of one's species but that does
not have to be the case and in the
particular thing I'm worried about has
to do with the evolution of domestic
dogs where we have a very asymmetrical
relationship but there is a certain
amount of culture transmitted between
people and dogs and vice versa and
miraculously the dogs have adapted to
this in ways that actually have physical
Hallmarks right their ability to um uh
exchange uh facial expressions right the
ability to control their faces in ways
that convey things um the amazing
ability that they appear to have to
understand human language to parse a
large number of different words uh all
of these things suggest a long-standing
relationship in which there is
transmission of a kind but anyway the
general case for culture is members of a
species transmitting information uh
outside of the genome and for human
beings this is elaborated far beyond
even our closest relatives because we
have language which makes it very
efficient and opens the possibility to
what is uniquely the case in humans the
ability to transmit abstract ideas
between
individuals now in our book we divide
two kinds of transmission of information
right what we call
Consciousness is about novel ideas that
are parallel processed between Minds
right um what we call culture in the
narrow sense in the book are things that
come from ancestors who generated ideas
consciously and then those ideas get
driven into an efficient cultural
package that that is passed on one
generation to the next and provides the
substrate with which new members of the
population are uh brought into the fold
and uh trained in how to
behave Brett I want to ask you another
question uh which has to do with uh your
famous research in telome I I came to
ask the question I guess in the
following sense is there an analog of
cultural telr are there analoges of
cultural
telr I'm have to think more deeply about
whether the tiir themselves are have an
analog but there is a very disturbing
analog to the process of sence that uh
we have fairly long understood in
evolutionary biology right this is the
process that causes creatures like us to
grow feeble and inefficient with age and
we have known since roughly 1957 when
George Williams published his excellent
paper on the evolution of C Essence why
it occurs why it evolves the short
answer being that your genome isn't very
big which means that the genes in your
genome tend to do more than one thing
and anytime a gene does something good
for you early in life it will tend to be
accumulated by selection to be enhanced
and passed on even if it does something
harmful to you late in life the reason
being many individuals don't live long
enough to suffer the late life cost so
they get away with it um and even for
indiv ual who do live long enough to
suffer the late life cost much of their
reproduction is already behind them and
so the selective disadvantage is
small okay so that's the reason we have
a genome full of genes that do two
things that give an early benefit at a
late life
cost the problem is that our
civilization has an analogous process to
it it's almost uh almost beyond the
level of analogy and the basic point is
when we invent a new process that Pro
that produces some benefit to us
initially it creates political and
economic power that makes it impossible
to undo that process if it turns out to
have a much later cost and so in exactly
the same way that the body suffers all
of those late life costs after a number
of years civilization is built in its
current instantiation it is built to
sesse by virtue of us suffering all of
the costs for the economic activity that
produced profit
uh long ago and um if we are wise we
will recognize the degree to which that
tells us where we're headed and we will
figure out how to unplug that system and
replace it with something that doesn't
have that
characteristic very good yeah that kind
of um kind of pre-aged my final question
to the both of you which is is America
experiencing cence uh and I do see some
yeah potential uh maybe over torturing
of that analogy but it does seem in
certain sense maybe Heather you can you
you read a passage in the book you talk
about how to avoid it and you talk about
Liberation antifragility and uh the the
propensity for for things that aren't
resilient or don't to resist competition
um maybe talk about that in the final
minutes and then I'm going to turn to my
patented final thrilling three
existential questions I'm gonna ask both
of you separately I've never done this
before uh but we'll use the remaining
minutes to do that is America
experiencing it and if so how can we
avoid it it it does it does appear that
way uh and I guess what I was going to
ask you brat as you were talking um
something I'm not sure we've ever even
talked about before um is individuals
experience cesses cence for the reasons
that you lay out and uh within a species
we will we can we can extend average
lifespan but we have very little chance
of extending maximum lifespan um but I
don't think there's any reason to think
that a societal level that there needs
to be a maximum lifespan right and so we
talk in the book for instance about the
Maya and an example of a civilization uh
that was so long lived and so um so long
Horizon thinking that they actually have
a unit of time the baktun which is over
400 years right so uh you know and they
had an Enlightenment of their own and
they introduced the concept of I mean
they invented the concept of zero and
astronomy and farming and written
language and you know they they had so
many of the things that the European
Enlightenment in fact did and yet they
were failing before the Spaniards
arrived right it was not it was not the
Spaniards who took out the Maya although
they certainly helped put you know
finish them off so you know
what they lasted longer than America has
uh so even if there were a maximum
lifespan of civilizations were certainly
not there and depending on how you count
uh China has certainly been going for
longer um although you might argue that
it's not the same it's not the same
civilization right um so you are we are
we in the Death
Rows well it seems like it but maybe
there don't need to be Death Rows no I I
think I think biology just has answered
this question and we've become so petty
that we don't understand that it's an
answer right and I think we need to look
to the biological solution to this and
then look for its analog in uh in the
space of civilization the way selection
has solved this problem is that it has
treated the body as a temporary vessel
and in fact the very model that we
present in the book where we pass on a
tremendous amount of adapting evolving
information outside of the genome means
that you have children they can pick up
that fraction of what you know that is
still relevant right they can discard
the fraction that has become outdated
and they can advance the ball and that
effectively
they are you but they are not exactly
you right they are an edit on you that
then keeps the process developing
through time they are the the
antifragile solution to the syence
problem and in essence what we need to
do with respect to the United States for
example is recognized that the founders
absolutely nailed it with respect to the
values they came up with a solution that
was actually in all likelihood much more
durable than they expected it to be but
it is now not surprising that people who
had never seen a train or a chainsaw or
an airplane or the internet that they
you know they couldn't have built a
structure that was going to be robust to
this and it is time for the 2.0 version
something that honors what they
accomplished but does not treat it with
religious devotion treats it as
something that now needs to have its
Offspring that's where we need to go and
I don't think it's a sad thing I think
it is a a natural transition and we
should embrace it actually if I can just
um put a cap on that uh we don't talk in
the book about species Concepts and how
it is that we name species and how
different types of biologists think
about what a species is but one of the
things that is certainly true is that um
as species change over time absent
branches coming off of them where we can
absolutely say yes that's different now
um we we still tend to paleontologists
still different names to those lineages
over time because they are what is found
is fossils and fossils get different
names and when if we think about
political systems the same way America
is changing we have these unchanging
founding documents uh but as it changes
over time just because it doesn't change
names doesn't mean that the thing itself
can't can't evolve interesting okay uh I
lied that I only had a couple questions
because I actually have my audience
questions but I'm going to do those in
Rapid Fire if you guys will play along
um I'll will read a question you could
say yes or no or restricted to a one-
sentence question it could be both of
you guys either one of you guys uh
they're not directed uh to either of you
individually but as a group first from
LJ do you have any thoughts on the
origin or purpose of music is it merely
a social tool meant to strengthen bonds
within or between groups or you think
it's a bond that could be separated from
evolutionary history one sentence go
um music passes the Adaptive test which
we present in the book with flying
colors it has no choice really but to be
an evolutionary adaptation modern music
has many purposes the question is what
is the original purpose that caused the
thing we call music to evolve and it's a
great question uh it can't be answered
in one sentence good okay d 2 asks
Explorer modes what are they and how
important are they for the process of
evolution most explorers fail and we
never hear from them again absent
explorers uh we don't have uh lineages
branching and we have uh a very low
diversity and expansion into diverse
habitats on the planet so I will I will
add
um Evolution seeks modes and forms that
function that get genes into the
future it is much less efficient to
search all of the possible design space
for modes that work than to limit one
search to things that are likely to be
functional selection over time will
develop mechanisms that reduce the cir
space those are the Explorer modes the
they heuristics of space yeah of and
then combined with survivorship bias
that we tend only to hear from the ones
that survived uh results in some quite
prejudicial uh outcomes supposedly okay
next question comes from Blair James
Ryan he has a question similar to the
one I wanted to ask uh your thoughts on
how the modern diet and processed foods
like seed oils and sugars have created
obesity and diabetes heart disease and
dementia now I wasn't familiar with
dementia but um maybe uh one of you can
take that and then I have a follow-up
question about allergies absolutely they
have and there is increasing evidence uh
for their role in dementia as well
including some of I can't remember the
name a few of the molecules involved in
shelf stability um that absolutely are
involved in uh things like Alzheimer's
and
Parkinson's I had a question about uh
allergies um so I'm only allergic to one
thing which is not uh which is stopping
eating I I get I break out when I stop
eating um but uh I never remember you
know glutenfree and peanut allergies
when I was a we lad 40 50 years ago uh
what do you guys make of this is this a
byproduct is it why are we hitting this
you know hockey stick moment with where
it seems to be so prevalent you can
hardly go to a restaurant which isn't
like all these symbols and and they're
not like kosher symbols so yeah what
does it make of the exponential increase
of these of these uh uh allergies well I
think there are two things that are
likely in play one of them allergies are
typically mediated by the IG system and
the IG system is a system that would
have been busy with things like
parasitic worms in a past environment
things that we've been very effective at
eliminating which is a good thing
imunoglobulin e yep it's a class of of
antibody and in any case there is
substantial evidence that suggests that
this system left idle targets things
that it shouldn't right it Target pollen
grains or whatever else but then there's
also hold on which is very much the
argument we make with regard to the
appendix in the book as well right
another biological fence right yeah so
the other thing is that there is there
are various factors that are causing the
immune system to to either be overactive
or to see things that it is not supposed
to for example um most of the immune
system is not supposed to see the
contents of your gut and the reason it's
not supposed to see the contents of your
gut is that when you are very early in
development the system looks at every
molecule that you yourself make and it
eliminates the subset of cells that
react to it and what that produces after
you past the stage of development is a
very elegant system system that sees
every Invader but does not see you and
this system can screw up right if this
system sees things it shouldn't it can
react to things that are a normal part
of life like foods that you eat and it
can react to them as if they're
potentially pathogenic it can also react
to your own cells creating an
autoimmunity and so allergies to things
that we eat appear to be the result of a
mistake by the self- nonself recog
nition system that causes the equivalent
of an autoimmune disorder not to you but
to your food right why are the contents
of our gut being seen by the immune
system and therefore recorded as likely
pathogenic that is an open question
there are many possible answers but I
think we need to be looking in this uh
this realm and we need to say Well it
may be too late for some of us I have a
severe wheat allergy there's nothing I'm
likely to be able to do about that but
what we can do is we can figure out what
causes this and then prevent young
people from encountering whatever those
influences are so that they don't
develop these an these allergies in in
future
Generations uh next question comes from
JM uh what types of adaptations would
you expect in populations that are
chronically vitamin D
deficient well um I I feel like we know
the answer to this and I just am not
remembering it's it's it's rickets it's
it's weak bones it's short stature it's
deformed bones but there's more than
that there's there's intellectual stuff
as well and I can't remember exactly
what but the question was what
adaptations do you expect to see yeah so
I think the answer
is um because of the nature of tradeoffs
and that there are certain to be
tradeoffs involved
in um the production of vitamin D what
you would expect to see is things that
increase the productivity of vitamin D
so vitamin D is produced by the skin in
response to
sunlight
the ability to produce vitamin D will
exist in a trade-off relationship with
other things so for example you might
expect to see a reduction in melanin in
populations and that reduction in
melanin is not going to be free it comes
to the cost like the more likely to
produce tumors but I would expect to see
a shift in the tradeoff between the
production of vitamin D and resistance
to other things where the body accepts
more vulnerability in some other Regard
in order to reduce the cost of uh
insufficient vitamin D maybe similarly
um paler hair and thinner hair right and
one other thing is I would also expect
so what we've so far talked about are
things that are likely to be wholly
transmitted in uh the genome but you
would also expect behavioral
compensations right so you might imagine
the traditions of people who are
chronically low in vitamin D might
involve uh pursuing sunlight when it is
available in spite of the cost to uh
retention of heat for example you might
expect Traditions to include things in
the diet which contain vitamin D we in
fact know this to be the case uh and so
anyway basically the point is you would
expect selection to find every
alteration of belief Behavior structure
uh that will cause an increase in the
production of vitamin D or a
preservation in vitamin D that's already
been produced and what otherwise be
destroyed you would expect selection to
find all those things over time and
accumulate them so someone named jarge
4999 that was actually the name I was
going to choose for my first kid what is
the future of biological inquiry are
there still major gains to be made in
terms of evolutionary theory do you see
things taking a major molecular chemical
term
there are massive advances yet to be
made and um largely unfortunately we've
stalled out in part due to the uh the
financial model of the modern University
which encourages very expensive research
over theoretical research which tends to
be far cheaper I also think that there's
a cultural bias you know we're very
early in the study of biology and it's a
very complex topic it is the most
complex topic really and so we should
expect ourselves to still be fumbling
around with some Basics but the degree
to which biologists you know if you look
at the bio101 textbook it reads just as
encyclopedically as the chemistry 101
textbook right and that's an indication
that something is gone wrong and if you
listen into the you know the the intro
series to biology you don't hear a lot
of here are 47 things we don't know the
answer to yet they don't include the
black boxes just gloss right over them
which is crazy because if you want to
train the mind that's the place to do it
let's hang out inside this box for a
while and see if we can figure our way
out yep all right uh next question is
about a spin 14 generalization of uh
unification of quantum mechanics and
relativity I that's for that's for
Heather um no that's the wrong Weinstein
brother here sorry about that Sean G uh
next last question I'll take from the
audience this guy has a lot he wants you
guys to have n Chomsky on past guest on
the into the impossible podcast
because he claims and we're making
finger puppets of you guys uh but he
claims that Chomsky uh finds convincing
this communication is not even a
secondary function of language uh he
goes on to other questions but he asked
five other questions I'm gonna ask just
one simple one Heather do peacocks use
their sons as decoys to Shield their
daughters no uh I'm not sure I even
understand the framing do you know do
you know what is being yeah I kind of I
kind of get it but um do you want to
transl for me and I'll is is not the
right term but the
idea the idea is if you were to um if
you were to go straight handicap right
as a hobby handicap principle um then
the point is from the point of view of a
male offspring that puts on this tail to
demonstrate he could deal with the
handicap yes he demonstrates awesome
genes because he's got the handicap but
he also suffers from the handicap and so
in order for that the opposite then
seems like the opposite of what is true
for it to pay the benefit to females who
get the benefit of the good jeans but
don't pay the cost of the tail has to be
effectively twice more than twice in
order to compensate for the loss to
their sons so it's not really decoy but
are they sacrificing their sons yes to
enhance their daughters and the answer
is no okay the answer well the answer is
no but it will not be obvious why the
answer is no I'm very much looking
forward to presenting that analysis at
some point in the future if you guys
have a few more minutes I know you have
a pretty hard break coming up but uh I
found very interesting and of course my
audience will be expect nothing less
than your thoughts on Aliens and you
make a statement in the book I forget
which one of you reads it but that
aliens will sleep when we encounter when
we encounter alien not if we encounter
but when we we they will be um you know
kind of nocturnal dial entities as well
as we what basis do you make that on
first of all Heather do you believe in
the existence of intelligent
extraterrestrial beings and Brett if you
think so why do you believe that they
will have dial and nocturnal behaviors
like we do yes and I really hope that we
find
them and it's it'll be a very good thing
if they do uh also sleep because then if
they come by while we're asleep they'll
know to wait until we're we're up
because we wouldn't want to miss them
right that's right no that's right that
would be embarrassing yeah and maybe
they can help me sleep train one of my
kids that would be nice right if you
want to know why yes yeah well the the
argument is like this um in order for
creatures to be sophisticated enough to
engage in this kind of travel there are
certain things that are very likely to
be true of the planet that they evolved
on um a day and night is a highly likely
phenomenon should they have a day and
night it is likely that just as the
creatures of Earth are biased towards
activity in one or the other period
because there are trade-offs and the
building of things like eyes for example
so if you have a really great Dial Eye
it tends not to collect enough light for
night and if you have a really great
amplifying uh eye then it tends to not
be so acute during the day and so those
things will cause a highly intelligent
creature to have faced a period of time
over which it was not highly productive
and um simple dormancy is a huge
opportunity cost because if you've got
the kind of computer that can do really
careful thinking and it's offline
because you can't be productive because
your eyes aren't adapted to either day
or night that the selection will
inevitably discover that it can borrow
that apparatus and so it sleep is liable
to have some of the characteristics of
ours including possibly things like
dreaming let me just say that you
alighted what may be the most
interesting uh part but maybe the most
obvious to an astronomically interested
audience which is that the intelligent
aliens that land here and wonder and
don't wonder why we sleep are likely to
have day and night because a tidily
locked planet is unlikely to have
allowed for the evolution of such
complex life that's right and that
actually comes to mind the last question
uh which has to do with uh the potential
danger then of a future space force
Colony on the moon which uh does not is
tially locked to the Earth and therefore
doesn't experience Dalal fast forward
you know many thousands of years in the
future um you know I often say like we
live in an amazing age you talk about
the campfire Etc my grandmother guys I
mean she grew up with the horse and
buggy she grew up you know in the
Shettles of of Eastern Poland and and
live to see men walking on Tik Tok but I
want to ask you if if
if we do go to the mo will there be will
there be um detriment you know will
there be kind of topul two cultures that
will arrive you know those that kind of
had the whatever benefit perhaps of
growing up in a dial non- tily lock
system or whether it be you know
detrimental to people living on on the
moon it will have anatomical and
physiological effects it will uh and we
don't know what all of them are just as
as much as we tried to figure out before
the space race was a thing uh what all
of of the effects would be of those very
short periods um in in you know in in
spaces without gravity for instance
would have we still could not begin to
actually fully understand it but but
wait I'm I'm a little bit lost here
because if we put a colony on the
moon it will have day and night they'll
be two weeks two weeks long right
but I mean biotically speaking the Moon
is not a high productivity environment
can we just all agree on that right yeah
in fact it's a zero productivity
environment so you know it's all going
to come by Amazon or something right
it's going to be shipped there and
therefore the idea of a productive
period during the day is going to be off
the table right you're going to be
productive we're going to create uh a
day and night cycle that is however long
is optimal for humans likely something
like 24 hours although when we put
people in caves it doesn't turn out to
be 24 hours but doesn't matter 25 right
um but nonetheless we'll just build
artificial environment I mean I'm not
advocating for hanging out in the Moon
it doesn't sound like a ton of fun to me
but right but I mean I think I I think
maybe part of what the question that
you're asking ends up getting at is one
of the one of the big themes of the book
that we haven't really talked about is a
tendency towards reductionism in modern
science and you know imagining that the
thing that you can measure that the
metric that you've got in hand is the
most important thing about the system
and so in order to survive in a colony
on the moon we will figure out those
basic things you know people are not
going to find themselves as fixating
because we got that thing wrong um but
we will not have gotten to a lot of the
emergent necessary truths that humans
will need in order to live like we do on
this planet and lucky for Elon as he
says uh he wants to die on Mars as Lord
Martin Reese's past guest on the show
said yes but let's hope he doesn't die
on impact uh Mars has a 20 almost
24-hour cycle so that would a dial
nocturnal cycle okay guys I'm gonna ask
you to do something I've never done
before if you'll indulge me which is one
of you guys is going to answer my
thrilling three exential questions about
about advice to your former here are the
three questions and I'd like you to
unplug your headphones one of you at a
time so I can uh have the other one be
uh ignorant of the others answer and I'd
love to hear you guys answer
independently if that's okay okay but
the problem is whoever takes off their
headphone is going to hear the answer to
the question so it's not a I mean you
want one of us to leave maybe you could
leave yeah maybe one of you could leave
or put on some heavy metal music uh
who's leaving uh you go first I mean I'm
going to speak first you you get out
here I'll go do the leaving and uh okay
I'll see you shortly
okay good thanks guys never happened
before right on the into the impossible
podcast okay Heather these are basically
either far future questions or far past
questions I like to ask all my guests to
kind of bring out the humanity and all
my guests uh not that you guys need any
but um but they involve around kind of
questions of Legacy which is prominent
in this book I want to ask you first uh
what you'd put in your ethical will
which is a concept from Judaism called
the Zava uh it's as a type of wisdom or
value system that you most would like to
articulate to near-term Generations as
their inheritance sort of a a will for
your ideological errors not necessarily
your only your biological erors so uh a
you know a set of instructions or wisdom
or compilation of of value system that
you live by sort of you know relatively
brief yeah I I guess this is going to
sound like it's cheating but I think uh
I think it's this book that we just
wrote and um if I have to encapsulate it
more uh it's perhaps the epilog uh which
is the eight eight things eight
principles that we say during the eight
nights of Hanukkah and I won't be able
to to say them off the top of my head
here do it anyway we want the audience
to buy the book
yeah great and the next one goes a
little bit farther into the future now a
billion years into the future and you
probably seen the movie 2001 A Space
Odyssey based on Arthur C Clark where I
am the associate co-director of the
Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination open yeah in the opening
scenes uh there are these primates in
the savannah of Africa and they come
upon one of these ominous monoliths and
I want to ask you we don't know what
they're for they could be a time capsule
to be discovered by humans or some other
civilization you know betokening our
existence um so I want to ask you what
would you put on your monolith something
destined to last billions of years uh
it's it has some similarity to the
famous question that Richard F asked you
know what scientific knowledge in his
case would you uh encapsulates the most
knowledge in in his field of physics in
the fewest words so I want to ask you
what kind of information or statement
about things that you've learned in your
life would you most want to put on a
monolith a time capsule to beoken our
great achievements as a human species I
guess it depends on whether or not these
are our descendants um undisturbed and
therefore they are proceeding a pace
from here or if if life has has
disappeared and this is a new Evolution
you know descent with modification is
the simplest definition of
evolution uh and it it is the
encapsulation of what explains what we
are so if I have to go very very simple
I think I would do that to sent with
modification great and the last question
of my thrilling three final questions uh
has to do with going back in time not a
billion years but just uh 20 30 years I
want to ask you uh Sir Arthur C Clark he
had many laws one of which is in every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert he said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic and I actually have his voice
reading that phrase when I open every
podcast but Heather one of his law his
questions is actually how I got the name
for this podcast and he said the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to go beyond them into the
impossible so that's the name of this uh
podcast but I want to ask you Heather uh
what thing about life mystified you as a
20year old a 30-year-old what advice
would you give to that former self to
give you the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible well
there's it's a little earlier but
there's a way in which you know I like
all teenagers I think was searching for
meaning and uh searching not just for
you know what my place was in the world
but really explicitly searching for what
what was this all about and uh you know
again this this will seem single note
but to me it's you know it's it's all
explanatory except for really domain and
the domain of of the very very tiny and
abiotic so you know quirks and rocks and
quazars are off the table but pretty
much everything else is evolutionary so
you know I was experimenting with uh
Buddhism and other religious traditions
and actually Brett handed me a book by
Dawkins um when I was you know 19 or 20
and said I think you will find things
here in that you will find explanatory
and uh it certainly wasn't complete but
it revealed to me a way of framing the
world uh that I I keep with me to this
day and also what it part of what it
promises is that we will never know
everything that you know of course the
act of science is to try to discover
what's true and we are aiming to get to
an Ever more accurate refinement of our
understanding of reality but we're not
going to get there in our lifetimes and
that's part of what is so marvelous
about it okay Brett I I asked your
lovely wife Heather these three
questions that I've asked your brother
um and uh all of my guest the answers
right there's going to be homework at
the end of this Brett you know that
always okay all right so these are
existential questions two of which will
go deep into the future your own
personal future when you spring forth
this Mortal coil at the biblical age of
120 or more perhaps you can extend your
life and your telr uh but I want to ask
you first what you'd put in your Zaba
your ethical will that is what wisdom or
values would you like to you know
inculcate or articulate to Future
Generations biological but mostly your
ideological errors that come after you I
think the answer here is actually simple
and it's very biological but I believe
that if one extrapolates
from from what I'm about to say that one
recovers all of the
important uh moral and ethical stuff the
idea
is we are obligated to to try to
provide the experience of a liberated
human
existence as liberated as possible to as
many people as we can that the the
marvelousness of being a human being is
so special and
unique that given that what we do
affects how many people will get to
experience it we have an obligation to
behave in a way that Max maximizes that
number and the reason that I think that
the all the proper moral and ethical
stuff that needs to flows from
extrapolating from that principle is
that a it forces you to behave in ways
that are maximally
sustainable those maximally sustainable
ways
therefore uh involve the discovery of
the various steady States we will need
and in order for the human life that we
deliver to those in the future for it to
be truly liberating we will have to have
addressed their many concerns that is to
say to be meaningfully liberated rather
than just nominally liberated you have
to have your mundane concerns addressed
so we would end up uh I think if we
really worked on this puzzle we would
end up protecting people from things
like bad luck we would end up connecting
them uh together in ways that caused
flourishing when people discovered
insights or created uh enhancements to
human well-being they would end up
needing to suffer some sort of a penalty
when they externalized harm onto others
and I think that this would Cascade all
the way through the social
architecture such that even to
interpersonal relationships it would
cause the right values uh to be enhanced
very good although slightly awkward
because Heather just extoled your
virtues for about five minutes straight
and uh now I can say you didn't
reciprocate okay next up no she didn't
do that no okay next we're going to go
deep into the future and you probably
are undoubtedly familiar with Arthur C
Clark's famous book The Sentinel which
led to A Space Odyssey in which there
are these monoliths that the prehistoric
creatures in Africa these hominid like
figures encounter and they hit it with a
bone and later it appears on the moon
and Clark doesn't really reveal what
these things are and of course I am the
associate co-director of the Arthur C
Clark Center for human imagination here
at UC San Diego so it's near and dear to
my heart I want to ask you if these are
thought of as time capsules as sort of
monoliths that are meant to encapsulate
or beoken things that Humanity has
learned or achieved what would you put
on your monolith and it's it's sort of
similar to fineman's cataclysm question
in which he said if in some cataclysm
all of human knowledge were destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures what
statement can contains the most
information in the fewest words I want
to ask you in your field he put forth
the atomic hypothesis uh what do you
think would encapsulate the most
knowledge that we've acquired in the
fewest most condensed compressed form of
a statement on a billion yearl lasting
Time Capsule that is so I'm stuck here I
I I must say uh 2001 is one of my
favorite stories and I've done a lot of
thinking about the monoliths but I've
never thought about them as time
capsules at all they seem to me more
like triggers but okay so if you had if
you had to preserve one
concept you know what it would
be it's actually it's in our book um
it's a
figure and the figure is stacked
diminishing returns
curves
because every complex system in which
there is an
objective
will show a pattern of diminishing
returns and the key to success at
whatever the objective might be is
knowing when you've hit the inflection
point and would be foolish to keep
investing in the same way and what you
need to do is seek the next um face the
next bargain phase of the next curve in
the stack and if people understood this
I believe you know I think it's right up
there
potentially wow I shouldn't say such a
thing um it is a dim shadow of yinyang
right which I find a very compelling
concept the idea of a symmetry that is
about compatibl rather than
sameness right um and I believe if if
one understands the implications of the
Stacked diminishing returns curves one
is in a better position to uh maximize
whatever is sought very good okay now
we're going to go back in time not
billions of years not millions of years
in the future we're going to go
backwards in time and quote Sir Arthur C
Clark his famous Third Law which states
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible is to venture a little
way past them into the impossible and
that's the origin of the name of my
podcast I want to ask you Brett what
mysterious aspect of life perplexed you
as a as a 20-year-old 30-year-old even
um but that what advice would you give
to that young man to give him the
courage to do as you've done to go into
the impossible well I'm not sure exactly
how to answer the question I certainly
believe in this principle and I have
advocated that um while arrogance is a
bad thing we can all agree that if one
has to air in One Direction or the other
it's far better than humbleness
because humbleness if you feel obligated
to um to view yourself as less capable
than then you will fall short of what
you might be able to achieve whereas if
you believe beyond your actual
capabilities that you might be capable
of something you'll at least find out
what you can do and you won't leave
anything on the table so I I believe in
the principle that you have to go beyond
in order to figure out what is uh what
is within range you know I had the
tiir um
experience was transformative it was
very early for me it was you know as a
young graduate student and and the
experience of having correctly predicted
that wild mice would have short tiir
even though the literature said many
many times over that mice have long tiir
and even in some places said rodents
have long
tiir discovering that I had been correct
about that that I had done the logic
well enough that it could predict a
result in a
Laboratory
um was very freeing
because after that point it didn't
really matter if people you know doubted
my capability I knew that at least once
I had succeeded in that and I never had
to worry too much that you know I was
fooling myself or something along those
lines so I would I would advise people
and in fact I have advised my own
students to seek an experience that
frees you in that way right to to
to um set OB objectives for yourself
scientifically and otherwise that even
if it takes many such attempts to find
something in which you discover the
limits of what you can do that it at
least allows you to to tune out the
doubters because you know they can't
possibly be
right and you need that confidence in
order to uh to succeed especially in a
very Cutthroat field like Academia I
always call it the academic Hunger Games
conversations past and present with your
elder brother I want to thank you so
much for coming on the into the
impossible podcast uh for having your
courage uh to produce this work there
are about 50 other questions I could
have asked but time does not permit me
nor does discretion uh do so as well but
I want to uh recommend everybody please
do pick up a copy of a hunter gatherers
Guide to the 21st century I'm looking
forward to the bonus uh guide that comes
with a poisonous tree frog that would be
a delight um and I just want to thank
you for sharing your honesty your
courage uh your candor with myself and
my audience and I hope we can uh meet up
again someday it has been a terrific
pleasure thank you this was great thanks
Brian thank you guys